We started Twitter with a very simple idea.
We started because we wanted to see it.
We loved it,...
...and we kept building it because we wanted to see other people use it.
There's a series of moments, there's no one big moment.
And each time is like, "Oh, that's happening?"
Well, that means this other thing may happen,...
...and then who knows what might happen next.
We just never thought it would go this way,...
...and I honestly think that's part of the reason why we succeeded.
It's such a simple tool, yet people have done so many amazing things with it.
You're able to have these multi-directional conversations.
You're not just broadcasting, you're there in the middle of it.
I'm gonna make history here as the first president to live tweet.
I'm using Twitter to send pictures and thoughts from space.
And every day, I really enjoy reading your tweets.
There's an incredible leveling of the playing field...
...that gives every voice the ability to act all around the world instantly.
And that democratization of content creation and sharing...
...facilitates these connections that we see every day around the world...
...that we would have never seen before.
The possibilities and the opportunities afforded by the platform are limitless.